[Musique]
tu m'as posé les yeux pour la première fois
j'aime la façon dont tu t'es arrêté sur le pas de la porte
et puis tu m'as vu et décidé de
me démarquer tu pensais alors que c'était le
coup de foudre en
fait je commence à le penser  était
[Musique]
il n'est pas comme les autres j'avais l'impression que ma
vie venait de commencer qu'est-ce qu'il fait c'est
un beatnik tais toi et il ne sait pas
la différence entre le croissant et
un bigot c'est pourquoi je l'aime
nous t'aimons Florence épouser  cette fille
Florence c'était beau rien ne s'est
mal passé même ma mère Bailey fait de
toi je pense que tu dois être la
personne carrée dans toute la civilisation occidentale
mais tu m'aimes
donc je t'aime
[Musique]
tu embrasses ton Brock
en fait j'ai un peu peur
[Musique]
tu veux savoir secret
quelque chose te tracasse je dois vraiment
y aller
[Musique]
il n'est pas trop tard pour rebrousser chemin
je sens son espace s'ouvrir autour de moi
on s'aime  et nous pouvons
nous libérer pour l'amour de Dieu Florence
som  Qu'est-ce qui ne va pas chez vous,
comment pensez-vous que vous êtes prêt
à vous faire oublier que nous nous sommes
mariés aujourd'hui, c'est
sans espoir
[Musique]